うーーーーーーゎぁーーーー(´Д｀)
運動でもしなきゃいけないから階段でも登るかぁ
…と思ってRTされた分階段を登ります
って言ったら20.839RT来てしまって
20.839段登らなくてはいけなくなってしまったはじめしゃちょー。
Ah~~~
こんなことになるとは思って・なかったYO★
えー一応ね、前半では　前半ではー、あのー、
まぁ、2千ちょい登ったんですけどー
もう
無理っす。あのー、正直。
これ一往復でもほんとキツイからね!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
やってみ！？
ただ言ってしまったことには責任が生じてしまう・・・
僕はーーーー・・・・
やりますよ。（ドヤ）
えぇ。（イケボ）
がんばるねぇ♡　　（（はい頑張ってください
（（頑張ってください
（（ガンバレ　ガンバレ））
ハァ///////
ハァ////////
ハァァァァン/////
ハァ////
うぉーし。
ハァ//////
（（Q.今の感想は？
あのぉー、太ももがやばいかも。
やる気はあるんだけど…足がついてこないすね
ちょっと休憩していい？
エグい・・・
エグいよ。
美男美女カップルがいるよ
うらやましいね。
折り返しますわ。
行ってくる
（（頑張ってください
（頑張ってください）
（（2往復で4636段です。
ｗｗｗｗｗ顔ｗｗ
あ"ーーー。
う”え”っ”しゅ！！
へっひゅ
うまく言えねぇけどさ・・・
いこうぜ！
うぁは～～～　（（あっつ
チャオ★　　（（ｗｗチャオ★
3往復目です・・・
約束は約束なんで・・・
RTされた分、僕は走りますよ。
きっつ（ボソッ）
ハァ
ハァァァン
そろそろ
余裕が……
じゃあ　降りるわ！
（（お疲れ様ですｗｗああｗｗ鼻水ｗｗｗティッシュｗｗｗ
うぉっしゃーー
３往復目お疲れ様です
3往復目？
これすげーわぁ・・・
（（やばいっすねぇ
陣地を超えてるわ(?)
（（楽しそうですねｗ
んー
いいなぁ。。。
こんにちは〜
みんな気をつけてね
登るぜ！
イッてくる！
俺ならイケるぅぅう！！
トゥラララララララ
余裕だ！
だんだん死んで行くはじめ
（（お疲れ様です
行って来るわ
イッてらっしゃい
走れはじめ！あの夕日に向かって！！
あと半分！！
まだふざける余裕があるはじめ！
もやっ　もやっ　もやっ　もやっ
もやっ　もやっ　もやっ　もやしっ
ここで何を取り出すはじめ！
SDだ！SDを拾ったぁぁあ！！
ここで余裕があることがバレたぞ！
ここで何を思うはじめ
死相が出てるぞはじめえええ
泣けるぜはじめ
最後まで決まらないはじめだ
当たり前かも知れないけど
信じたくはなかった
いつか
終わり
が来る
消えてしまうの
どうしてかな
一緒にいたい
もや〜しもやしもやし〜♪♬
もやし〜も〜やもや♪
もや〜♬もや〜♬
も〜や〜しもやし
も〜やし〜〜♪♬
最後は情けないはじめでした
今度はもっと倍以上にリツイートしましょう